alright let's not kid ourselves here the
xbox360 is old and technology terms it's
downright ancient but when you consider
which console to buy next the reasons to
own an Xbox 360 are more compelling than
you might think we'll start with the
library this is where the age of the
system works in its favor because the
list of games available for the Xbox 360
is absolutely insane you can choose from
no less than nine Call of Duty's six
assassin Creed's and two grand theft
auto's if you prefer indie darlings
you got spelunky braid Castle Crashers
and limbo just to name a few and then
there are the system exclusives Forza
Motorsport came of age on the Xbox 360
and halo continued to offer some of the
most exciting sandbox shooter action
around even after the series stewardship
transferred from Bungie to 343
industries with the excellent Halo 4 and
then you have Gears of War fable and if
you're okay breaking a sweat Dance
Central as for upcoming games the Xbox
360 still has plenty of titles coming
out this year Metal Gear Solid Ground
zeroes watchdogs and destiny will all
receive Xbox 360 versions and then there
are semi exclusives like titanfall and
Fantasia just do yourself a favor and
don't spend too long drooling over the
next-gen versions of these games you're
only going to regret it
while the first iteration of the Xbox
360 was plagued by hardware issues like
the notorious red ring of death and an
ambient noise level that could only be
described as helicopter like Microsoft
has improved the console Hardware
considerably with the S model in 2010
and the e model in 2013 these new
designs are far smaller and quieter than
the original version of the Xbox 360
that first came out in 2005 but more
important than the aesthetics of these
new systems is the fact that they
continue to drop in price you can grab
the 4 gigabyte model of the newest
slimmest
Xbox 360 II for only $1.99 of course you
still have to pay $60 a year for Xbox
gold in order to watch streaming
services like Netflix which was
ridiculous four years ago and is even
more ridiculous today but as long as
you're prepared to swallow that bitter
pill the Xbox 360 makes an awfully
enticing purchase in 2014
you